Twice a week hey Michelle from Miami Debbie from Long Beach
Jude from Miami
AM from LA
LA, I was… I was just there.
What's up, David Young from Maine. Good to see you here again.
Massacle
John, Ian, Peggy, Kristen. Hey, Kristen, good to see you here again. Love Oceanside. I used to live in San Diego. Patricia from New York. I'm in Brooklyn right now. Margarine
Boston. I have a friend going to see the Scotland game on Friday
You're going
They're in the World Cup. No, my friend is, he's Scottish. He's going to the game in Boston World Cup.
He's pumped
Oh, nice, nice. I was about to say, and you're really globetrotting. You were just in Cali, you're in Nashville now, you're all over the world. Oh, we've got Aaron from Nashville.
Got another Nashville. All right, let's go.
Awesome, guys. Well, we've got about 40 of you in here now, so we'll get this started. So guys, as we mentioned, Ian has about 12-ish
I don't know what the ish means, Ian. It seems like a
Well, I…
It's… I've set up some for other people on the same thing, but I make their stuff read-only, so there are more bots, but I'm only using 12, so we'll say 12.
There he is.
Wow.
That's a good question.
Jean-Jacques, good to see you again. We had a good chat last time. Yeah, he's joining at midnight. How about that, guys? Hey, John, Dave, there's a few others who joined prior sessions. Chris and DeRosa. Just let the rest of the audience know what did you think of our past sessions? Is this a good use of time or should they run
Should they just run right now and get out of here and
Don't run. Don't run.
Yeah, yeah. Stay. Thanks, David. So amazing from Kristen. So good. Awesome. It was great, compact, informative, very articulate. Thank you, Ashwin. Good to see you again.
Hey guys, so Ian and I, we've been jamming out for a few years now on all things entrepreneurship. We, Jude, this will be recorded
We both have built several, I should say many businesses now. And we've become friends through it, especially during this AI gold rush that's been happening the past couple years. Ian's been a mentor to me in many ways
Onboarding me to AI. But one thing that Ian has always encouraged me to do that I just… I'm being so stubborn
being so stubborn, Ian, is setting up an open claw. Now, guys, I'll say the reason I haven't is because
Cloud Code works great for me
However, recently I've seen some chinks in the armor
And I see an opportunity
In my daily workflow that could save me a lot of time
Now, I'm not trying to replace myself necessarily
Because it does require a lot of human effort to get beautiful things built and done. But you know, Ian, the thing you really shined light on for me was, like, all these repetitive tasks. It reminds me of when I'm doing the dishes at home
or the laundry, cutting the lawn, cleaning. That's what I want my open claw to be doing.
on my desktop. I want it to be doing all the repetitive tasks I don't want to be doing. Guys, does that make sense?
What are your thoughts on that?
I wish they could do laundry. That would be awesome, but not yet. Maybe after what's Optimus or whatever Elon's robot's going to be. But yeah, I actually
I actually don't use mine too much for the repetitive stuff. I have it… because I kind of gloss over that, because I think of it as open claws, like putting on a mech suit
When you put on this mech suit, now when I swing my fist, I can break through a house and tear down a tree, you know, so it extends my reach, my ability so much more. That's why, that's why I don't
Earlier, we had talked about making AI employee. It's not really that. It's actually an AI extension of me. So I can do a whole lot more of what I want to do
And it's been
When I installed it, I installed it on my mom's birthday, January 24th, and I didn't sleep. I spent about 20 hours that week. No joke. I was up late and then I woke up early
Every night because I was so excited because this is really the time for people like us where we're builders, we're
We're forerunners, we're really early adopters. We're still very early in the game. And open class changed a lot since it started.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, I saw a stat the other day, only 1% of people in the world, if that, are using AI to code. A lot of people are just using it for rewriting emails and recommendations for where they should go on vacation and some very rudimentary stuff where nothing wrong with that, but
There's so much more power to unlock, and I'm really excited to have you do that for me, selfishly, and for our audience today. So guys, I hope that sets the stage for you, what's going to happen today, but I guess to set the stage further, we're going to do two things right here
Number 1, Ian, I want you to give us an idea by the end of this session, we have 49 or 51 minutes left. What is everybody going to walk away with today by the end of this hour-long session?
Let's see, specifically for this session, you will learn how to install OpenClaw on a virtual private server. Like in this case, we're using DigitalOcean
And how to secure it, and then how to plug in a model into it. A model is like ChatGPT or Claude. So open Claude is just a wrapper or a harness that you put around a brain. You got to use a brain though.
And so you'll learn all that stuff and then how to connect it to Telegram. So you can actually have it start doing stuff for you and working for you. Yeah, so that's what we'll come away with today, plus a lot of other little interstitial stuff, I'm sure.
Always, always.
Always.
Guys, so we're going to run this session about an hour. Ian and I like to hang out and stay a bit longer, so we'll do a Q&A at the end, but feel free to ask questions throughout if something's not making sense. Like Ian just said, a virtual private server and a brain and this, that, the other. I have a lot of questions for you, I'm sure the audience does as well, so guys.
Feel free to ask as we go. If we don't get to them, we'll get to it at the end in the Q&A. But sometimes there is a question that a lot of people are thinking at the same time, and no one's really asking it. So if you have a question, others are probably thinking it too, so feel free to ask right now
or at any point in the segment, and we'll address it if it's relevant. Second thing before we jump into Ian showing me how to set up an open claw, and I'm going to share my screen in just a moment, and Ian's going to walk me through it
Second thing is I dropped a link in the chat
AI for NTP, that's AI for non-techie people sessions 003 Assess. If you guys click that link
You're going to get prompted with something that looks like this
And what we want you guys to do is just fill this out
If you had an AI agent, what's one thing you'd have it do? Type it in here
And enter your name if you'd like. You don't have to
And we're gonna show you a little something we built with AI right before the session. It's fun, you know, and it's just a good way to get a sense of how you guys are thinking about using, I dropped it, sorry, I dropped it just to host and panelists. Thank you.
I was to hosting panels.
Thank you for that. You saved the day. Thank you, Fernanda. Bonus points for you.
An adult. Bernanda
So what's one task you'd have it do?
Laundry
Yeah, dishes, clean the house. Where's Optimus when you need him?
Not to go back there. Yeah. Mow the lawn.
He's coming
Ian, what's one task you'd have to do? You have it doing hundreds of tasks already. What's something you haven't
add your 12-ish agents do that you'd like to moving forward
That's a great question. Whenever I get a new technology, I love to push the boundaries and figure out where the edges are, where the perimeters are. And I have not found very many on AI
Found very few. But ones that I would like to get into are more in robotics, actually. I've heard you can install AI, maybe even OpenClaw, on… maybe not OpenClaw, but on Raspberry Pi
Which is like a little board, a little chip board, you know?
Mini computer, right?
And it can… you can connect it to mechanical things. What's that? Yeah, I mean, a computer, yeah, basically. So you can connect into things like, you know, arms and rotating things. Basically, it can move around and do things for you. I had a friend who made
a drone that connects to the back of his phone, just attaches to it, and sometimes if he… if he wants to
you know, check out an area he hasn't been, he'll pull it off, and it turns into this little camera, it little pops up, and turns into a tank, and he can go with his phone, zoom it all over this park or whatever, you know, look for animals
if there's snakes or something. Probably the next next
place I'll go with with it once I get into robotics.
Yeah.
Also, Ian, that's awesome. I'd love to meet your friend. Maybe we can bring him on the show, him or her on the show next time. So what you guys are seeing here is
you inputted your task.
And AI is telling you how the agent would actually go about this task. So
We can now look at the host dashboard, and this is… we have 16 submissions so far
I'm just gonna read a couple of these.
Great.
Outreach to new area landlords, developers, and brokers. Commercial real estate searches
We have Ian's
HubSpot is CRM, I'd love an agent that every day sends me top 10 to 20 prospects I forgot to follow up with or chase. I've built something similar before. Shoot me an email after this. I'll give you some good playbook for that
post to my Instagram feed. I've got a tool I can send you for that.
housekeeper or house helper. Yeah, wouldn't we all that'd be great.
This is
There it is
Fernando, you're killing me. You guys are killing me.
That's Fernanda.
We need Rosie
Manage emails, arrangements
Near Rosie
Ian, here's a good one for you
Ban guidelines
Didn't we just do that? Who was that?
Well, they are on session
Where is it?
Guys, just so
Like this is incredible. This is great because all of these are tasks that are super feasible with AI
All right.
I want someone to QC all the data analysis we conduct on a daily basis, which is fairly large valuations across multiple countries and weekly monitors. That sounds like a great task for AI. What do you think?
I think so. Yeah, that is much more serious, Fernanda.
I've actually done things like that. The thing you have to keep in mind with AI is, you know, we all have heard the term now, hallucinations. It's because they're vector databases, so they store data in 3D
And when they go look for an answer, it's somewhere between
parameters that you search for. And so sometimes it will hallucinate, because it's maybe not real world. And so when it pulls it back, it's fake, but there are ways to connect AI
LLMs to a tabular AI that actually has to go and find real-world data and has to verify
You see would work for that, reviewing different documents and things where you connect it to another one and say you have to find real world answers. You can't hallucinate this, and then it holds itself a lot more accountable.
But that's a great
Use case for it
Thanks, Eddie. Everyone, all 21 of you who have made a submission, there's
It's about 51 of you in the room now, so shout out to all 21 of you who have involved… who have participated
Excuse me. What I'm going to do with Ian is after this session, I'm going to go through each of these with Ian, and we're going to send you
A little gift for each one of your objectives
and steer you in the right direction. So, thank you all. Thank you, Mara. Thank you, Peggy. Good to see you again. Bonnie, Fernando, thank you for the real submission. Alrighty, what do you say we jump in? What are we doing next?
It's all yours, E. I need to set up an agent. I have no idea how to do it. What are the first steps here?
Well, the first step that we won't go over now is to get a host of EPS, Virtual Private Server
You can do this at a lot of places. Basically, it's just… it's the same thing as when you build a website. You put all the files on a website and point a domain name at it, and then every
the Internet knows, basically, when you go to that website, it shows those files. So it's the same thing as what we're using now. It just has to have a
GPU, not just a CPU. So it has to be like a video card in it. So which we do have actually no, these don't have to have GPUs. They just have to have a CPU. Sorry, it's getting a little technical, but just a regular old server
Justin, before the call
on DigitalOcean, and we're going to use the web console. It's like, I don't know if you guys have ever seen War Games or Terminal. It's that window, where it's just straight
Straight code, straight calls, straight
to the server.
So, Justin, if you want to pull that up
Okay, so you'd like me to open my terminal is the first step
We're going to open up that web console from DigitalOcean
Okay
Give me just a moment. Hey guys, if
Yeah.
We've got some questions here. Yeah, you can still send a submission. We'd be we'd be happy to help.
And Toby, yes, the session is being recorded.
So guys, we're going to jump into
Digital Ocean here
And now I'm going to share my screen
There are some things that we need to keep private during the session
Just so it's not exposed, because we're gonna post this on YouTube and send out this recording, so there are some things I have to hide my screen for.
But if you guys are doing this or following along
Either during the session live or during the recording, you'll be fine. You'll be safe. Everything that Ian has set up for us is secure and private. It's just because we're recording and sharing live. There are some things I can't share my screen for.
So I am now on digitalocean.com. So I'll drop that in the chat.
And Ian, what is DigitalOcean again and why do we need this?
It's just a server.
The bank of servers that pretty much everything on the internet runs on a server. So, that's all you're doing is buying a little bit of real estate, you know, monthly payment of a real estate in the internet. Someplace that can be… can reach the internet and can serve things to the internet. So it's just… it's
Peter on the internet
Okay, here we are.
All right, there we go. Okay, so I'm going to start hosting some
Calls, so the first thing we do before we want to install OpenClaw, I'm going to put this in chat, just so everybody has it too
Okay, Justin, can you see that?
I can see that
Okay, so take that and just plug that in. So we're not installing OpenCloud yet. We're just getting the server ready.
We're updating all the software
It's ready
Before we install it.
So go ahead and copy that and then
I would get more entries here.
Okay.
Yep.
Okay, so I'm just going to copy and paste that in and guys, I don't know what this code means, but that's okay because I just trust Ian. And this is just Ian, is this like
this is downloading some files, this is giving instructions. What is happening here exactly?
Go ahead and hit start and I'll show you. So it's basically
Logging in at the root and saying, update any software that's installed on the server. I mean, there's a lot more technical ways to say it, but that's pretty much what's happening. And then it's also installing fail to ban. Fail-to-ban is an IP
security, software that basically once you
Call, or once you set IP address or server, it has its own IP address, bots are going to start pinging it right away. Usually crypto spam bots
And so this just listens for those and if there's 5, they're trying to log in with your
your password, but they don't know your password, and they won't. So
Five times within, like, 10 minutes, or something like that
it'll ban that IP address, because it'll basically say you're obviously a bot, you're spam
And it bans it for like 24 hours. So it's a good
strong thing to start with because then it just leaves basically your computer's not being overloaded by you've heard of like DDoS attacks, denial of the service, you know where it's a bunch of bots that are attacking a server all at once. That's not what's happening, but you just don't want your server to be bothered.
While you're installing OpenCloud.
So that's what it's doing now. It's updating all these to
And all the software that's already on the server. This won't make any sense, you don't have to worry about it. There's no quiz after to know what this thing
is doing. Usually it freaks people out when they see all this code, because it looks like a hacker or spam or
chemical conversion is fine.
I think you just hit the enter button.
Yep.
And just hit enter. And then Toby was wondering, you know, I'm sure a lot of other people in the audience are wondering the same thing. How long did it take to get to this segment we started on? So guys, the only thing I did was went to DigitalOcean and signed up
It was, I think we did the $8 a month plan, and we were ready to go.
18, we did 18. You want to have for an open claw, you want to have at least two gigs of
CP
Like, RAM. It's much smaller than a laptop. Like, your laptops or computers are probably much bigger than this, but you need at least that, otherwise it starts to choke and it'll go a little slow. You can do it, as long as you're not giving it really intense things to do.
So yeah, and also DigitalOcean is just the one I've been using. I've used other servers, so I'm not, we're obviously not getting paid by them for promoting it, but
But yeah, it's the one I've gotten used to setting these up, and I've set a lot of these up.
Harden
And Ian, so just for context.
Maybe recording? Yes, okay, great.
I've been using
ChatGPT and Claude for I think I just got the three-year thousand day
First, let's see what this is about
Automatically download and installs table update. Yes
Okay, I'm going to hit enter
Enter
Great.
Okay, you said, oh, okay. All right, time for the next one. Okay. I'm going to paste this next one into the chat.
And we'll have this stuff available to you
No, well, every time you install
Every time
Does this code need to be installed every time I run DigitalOcean? Well, DigitalOcean is a server, it's like a computer. So you just have to do it one time when you set up DigitalOcean
And… but you can install a lot of bots on there if you wanted to.
things on that server. So, I've only done it 8 times, and honestly, after… after the first
Maybe second bot I installed, I just started having my bots install other bots, because it's so much easier, because they can troubleshoot a lot of stuff
And we have a good question for Mathwyn here
Okay, you can say yes to that
First code script prompts a password. Is that going to activate only after we have DigitalOcean accounts set up?
Did it prod did it
Just say don't
don't allow password where SSH into it. Yeah, we're blocking actually, I believe
Ian, we set up a password on DigitalOcean initially, I believe
We did.
Just, like, a login… a login password.
Yes, and then we connected your SSH key, which you don't have to do. I just like to do it just in case you need to log in like this through your own terminal. It's getting kind of techy, but that's not necessary.
But yeah, you will want to set up a password at DigitalOcean before you do all this, because… well, I think they'll require it. You can't just set up a DigitalOcean without one
Okay, so let's do
Gonna create a real
user. Actually, you know what, let's
So, you know, I just did the second
Yeah.
Okay, we're going to create
command. And what what was that doing? Pseudo Ufw default deny incoming
What's that? That one was firewalls, setting up firewalls on the server.
So basically just protecting it, giving it
Giving it a wall of protection
from
Any kind of hacker or spam. It's not like… I mean, if there's a hacker that wants to get in, that's a much more sophisticated one. This is mostly protecting against bots, or low-level
You know.
Rapid bot spam
Gotcha. So, and then Ian, we're just doing this once, all these commands, and then I'm going to have this agent just working for me that I can
Where am I going to be able to communicate it with or tell it to do things for me like
Hopefully one day my dishes, but for now
Once we do all this this initial setup, what's going to happen after this?
Well, at the end of this, you will connect it all the way to Telegram. There are other ways to connect OpenClaw
You can do it through. My favorite is Telegram, just because it's easiest, honestly.
And you can do your password, it won't… I don't think it's going to show
Let's so hot.
And you can do Telegram, you can use WhatsApp. You can use Slack. You can use messages
I think there are probably other ways, but those are the four biggies.
I tried to set up Slack at first, and I had to go and connect to Slack, and it just seemed a little more complicated than… I was really just testing it out.
But I got stuck with Telegram and I've been happy about it. So
So I just made my password 123 exclamation mark
You did?
I was like, you shouldn't do that, man.
Or say that on this live stream.
AVCD, money sign
Password is password
Okay, so, full name, are we naming our bot right now or
You can no, no, this is not naming the bot. We haven't installed him yet.
And you can put open space claw, that's his full name.
Open claw
Can this be connected to Google emails? Yes.
I wish… I don't know if I'll have time at the end to show you that, but yes, I've done it. It can even be connected to Google Docs, Google Calendar, and it can go through
I connected one for my daughter, and it was making changes and lurking around in there. She knew what it was. Her coworkers were like, hey, who's the
you know, anonymous person, and it was her bot. So, okay, room number, the new value press enter
33.
Yeah, I'm not sure
I like the way you think.
This is just for the
worked fine. You just hit enter.
For those of you who don't know, it's just my 33rd birthday. It's my lucky number, so we're just leaning in at this point. So
Work phone
I just hit enter. It's just asking for stuff. You can bypass it. Toby, no, you don't have to copy this code.
If you are following along, we were thinking of like a Bob Ross. I don't know if you guys, I may be dating myself, but Bob Ross, the painter, the big afro, he would always do his show set up so that you could follow along and paint just like him. And so we thought, oh, this would be fun to do it like that. So that's why I'm putting it in here. But if you don't want to follow along
He still plays in my gym all the time. It's always on there, it just… it's kind of too relaxing for me, actually
Okay, let's
We're not going to lock down SSH yet. We'll let the bot do that
Okay, so another one is I
Tailscale is a really good… if you guys are interested in a secure connection between your computer and the server, you can install tail scale. We'll do that later. The bot can actually do it for us. But that's a really cool software that we'll add to our list
after… yeah, there we go
It's pretty cool. I actually didn't know about it until I started working with OpenClaw, and it's the one that turned me on to it.
We will
So, Ian, in layman's terms, explain to me like I'm 10 years old. What is what is Tailscale doing for us and why would we want to add that to our open claw?
Tailscale is basically makes a
A funnel between your server and your computer, and it requires… it's like a VPN, actually, it's a VPN. So
Your computer has this certain IP address, and it recognizes that IP address. And it says nobody else except for this IP address, your computer's IP address. I have it for my phone too, and it's great because you can turn it on and you'll be able to pass things or see things
It's really for like competitive information that you don't want your competitors to see or sensitive information, financial stuff. I don't typically run that on the internet anyways, but I do appreciate, I even have timers like for my project, client projects
that I have… I just don't want anybody getting in there
So I created a tail scale funnel, and it worked great. So
So what we're doing now is installing Node, and then we're installing OpenClaw.
I believe
Yeah, I think it's doing all of it right now. So this is node is what is the software or the platform that OpenClaw runs on.
Okay, so no new major version of npm available
You could run that
To run update NPM install. So Justin, grab that little, you see the link. It's like a link npm
Down there, yeah. Grab all that.
And copy it and then just paste it.
And
You'll update node or npm
Microsoft products. Does this work with Microsoft products? It's
Oh, yeah, thank you. Oh, that was me. I thought someone posted the notes stuff. Microsoft, it can, if you can get in a terminal, I've heard it works best with
Mac or Linux, but this is a server, this is Ubuntu, so it's… it's Linux machine.
I actually don't know, I haven't done an install on Microsoft, Gene, so I don't or Gene or John, so I'm not sure how to do that yet.
And to put it in perspective, I'm on a MacBook right now. We're running Ubuntu through DigitalOcean. So in theory, doesn't matter which device you're on. If you're taking a similar process to what we're doing now
Yeah, yeah. And you can do it on a PC, but on an Ubuntu server, it's all the same thing because this is just a website that you're logging
Alright, Justin, you're gonna say, open claw setup. I'm gonna type that one in myself.
Type that in there
Oh.
Open cloud.
Not found, okay. Try, OpenCloud dash dash version.
And do it with a lowercase too
Open claw
But no, no, no, space, sorry, open class space dash dash version
Space dash dash version. It may not be installed yet.
Okay, so you do have open cloud. Okay, so let's go to type in
open claw space on board. One word
Nope. Nope.
Hope you put open
Okay, try that
For all of those of you who are just watching and following along, we're kind of like a technical part of this.
Not all that exciting yet, but we'll send all the instructions how you can do this from the comfort of your home on your own time when you see fit. And we'll let you know exactly how to do it start to finish like we're doing now
Yeah, and
E. What do we have here? Got a secure disclaimer
So this actually go up a little bit because OpenClaw is actually notoriously very funny. And so what's he say there? Type the command with confidence nature. Oh, wait
Type the command with confidence nature will
Confident nature stack trace if it's needed. It makes development jokes. So if you're a developer at all, you're going to love it. This is also just basically a disclaimer saying OpenGlaw is potentially dangerous because it's essentially
Right now, if you have a chat bot, an LLM
like ChatGPT or Claude or Grok, this takes off the walls and says it can do anything. And so when you give it access to anything, it can do anything, and you can hit yes on that, because we're gonna… you have to say yes in order to… you have to go over it, tap left
Daryl, there you go hit enter.
I did, yes
When you do say yes, or sorry, when you do give it access to everything
We'll do a quick start. Hit enter again.
Yes.
And OpenAI, that's what you want to use, right? So look at, here's all the models that it can work with
There's actually more, but
OpenAI
So, Yi, what would you recommend? I've heard from conversations, I have these conversations daily with founders, people building with AI. Some prefer open AI, some prefer Kimi because it's cheap. That's the hot new Asian model. Others prefer Anthropic. Ian, what do you use and why?
So for the first 10 weeks, like I said, I installed it on January 24th. On April 4th
Well, for those 10 weeks, I used Claude, Opus 4.6, and I was in heaven. It was awesome. And then April 4th, Claude Anthropic
I have a friend there, and I texted him out, it's a bummer, but here it is. They blocked OpenCloud from using Claude OAuth tokens. So OAuth tokens means it's using your subscription
and not extra tokens. So after that, I had to use extra usage, they called it. And I was paying
$200 a month for Claude, because I was burning them. I mean, I had a lot of things going at once. And after that, I ran very nimbly for a week, and I spent $200 that week in extra to usage. And so I said, I gotta find another… I'll be spending thousands of dollars
So I had to find another model, and I used KimiK25, KimiK2.5, which it was great actually for a little bit, and then it tended to get stupid. I'm not sure why
So it kind of messed some things up for me, and so I, I found OpenAI. A friend of mine told me
GPT-5. And I did not believe it because I was not a fan of ChatGPT or Sam Altman. I mean, I'm sure he's fine. Just some of the ways he's structured the business and moved it and stuff. I wasn't a fan of. So I was like, no, I don't want to use that
And he said, okay. And the next day he says, have you tried it? And I finally just gave in
Use it and use it now. ChatGPT 5.5.
And that's OpenAI.
Because I
And so you're spending a lot of money initially when they made the changes, but now could you run this on a fairly low budget? What do you think I'm going to spend per day using this or is it going to just be free included with my subscription that I pay to
OpenAI and Claude
Yeah.
It's included in your subscription because OpenAI hired a guy named Peter Steinberger, who was the creator of
And he made them, you know make make sure it was an MIT free license. So this will always be free as long as they hold to that. But he also encouraged them because
For cloud to block everybody, OpenCloud users were huge
Claude fans and users. But OpenAI, ChatGPT made it usable with your subscription. So you won't spend any money. I spent 100 bucks a month and I use about
Oh, wow
Maximum 30% of my weekly usage, because you still have a… you still have a limit
I have not reached it even close. So
Yeah. Okay, so this is where you can go. ChatGPT login
Now, let's go up to the… So API key would be extra usage. That's your tokens. So it's going to
Yeah
Okay, I'm gonna take this off screen
Select all that, pull that up
Yeah.
Because this is one of those things that you'll
You want to be careful with. So things to keep in mind when you get your open cloud going is don't ever expose API keys or passwords or OAuth tokens like this. I mean, this is not one, but he's going to get it.
Actually pull the whole terminal off, Justin, to paste in your
Authorization code
After you get it
Because you don't want to, you don't expose those, because that means someone could grab your
your ChatGPT and just start going crazy with it. And that's not great. I actually have a story about that while you're doing this. I was fairly… it was actually with Claude. It wasn't with Open Claude, but I
I guess that was fairly loose with my security at first, and I had SendGrid API keys. SendGrid is how you send a lot of emails. They send a lot of emails. And somehow he left it exposed in some public files, and somebody in France got a hold of it and sent out 127,000 emails
To people in France
From my email address
And I couldn't do anything about it, because Syngrid had already approved those emails. So
Fortunately, it turned out okay for us because we had about 95% reputation, which is really good
And very few people in France marked it as spam. So our reputation actually went up because so many emails went out and very few were marked as spam. But I did get cussed out a lot in French, so I know a lot of new words now
And the emojis are pretty much the same here as in France.
That was tough.
So avoid that
Alright, we're hitting an error.
We are saying that the site can't be reached
Yeah, that's fine. So grab the, actually, I'm glad you pulled this up. Pull the off screen again
Okay.
And you're going to grab that local
Post URL
Okay.
The whole URL and plug that into your open cloud when it's saying, paste the whole authorization code.
Plug that URL
into that. It's gonna feel weird, because it's like, it's
It's a
URL
Okay, it says it's installing now
Great.
French cuss words.
Yeah.
Yeah
Man.
Yeah, Ian's got a lot of war stories with AI in the past several years. It's one of
Yeah
One of many, hopefully one of few in the future, but I doubt it. I moved faster to break things.
Alright, is the, is the token off the screen yet?
Justin.
It is installing. The token still in the DigitalOcean terminal
Okay, so wait until that's gone because it'll
It'll scroll off
Okay, it's asking me that it's still on the screen, so I'm gonna go through the next series of questions
off screen for just a moment, and then we're gonna pull back on screen, and then Ian, once this done is all done installing
Yeah.
What are we going to build? Are we gonna make this agent go live and do some cool stuff for the audience? We've got 20 minutes left and some Q&A. What are we gonna do when this is done installing?
Yeah, we'll have them out. Well, I mean, there's so many things you can do with them. So at first when I started going, I really just started brainstorming business ideas. And I said, hey, I want to, okay, here we go.
Okay, let me pause my story, our channel. So you want to go down to Telegram, see all the different options here. Telegram's what we'll use
And this is we're selecting how we want to communicate with our agent and give them tasks. Is that what this is?
Yes, this is how you're going to connect to it and talk to it. This is how on the call I was opening my Telegram chat. This is how I talked to him through that. So hit enter
It's gonna ask you for the bot API.
Okay, so now pull up Telegram
Is it there? Okay
Okay, so go up into search
And type in
One word bot father.
Nope.
There we go.
There he is. That's the guy. Okay.
So you're gonna hit start
And he's going to say, hey, what do you want to do? And you're going to say, you can pick, you can type slash new bot, I think.
slash newbot
Yep.
I was gonna say, okay, great. What do you want to call your bot?
What do you want us to
Guys, drop in the chat. What should we name my first bot
Wow, crowdsourced bot names. This is
Let's see you guys come up with
Mara, just shoot me an email, happy to chat.
Possibly.
Yeah.
If we don
I'll, give you Ian's contact information, my contact information in a follow-up email as well.
Darian, you certainly can re-watch a shoot me an email, justin at AI4ntp.com, and I'll get the recording and show notes to you.
Okay?
Debbie wants to call it bottle. That's an option. We can call our first bot bottle. That's kind of cute
Tangya
Tango, I like that
Okay, please, yes.
Darian, once you're
Your email for NTP. I like that.
On brand
That's clever
And Alphabot. All right, Aaron
Alphabot
You know what? I think Debbie was the first mover. She gets the first movers advantage bottle. It's kind of cute
Okay.
I can run the bottle. What do you guys say? Guys, drop a comment in the chat if you like bottle
Let's make sure we're making a good decision here.
This is tough. I like all those bottleneck
But
Hopefully not.
That's good. Oh, the irony.
Okay.
All right
David likes it. If David likes it, I like it. David's one of our longtime community members from the very beginning, so
Let's roll with it
So it's going to say
Great. So go ahead and hit enter
And he's gonna ask you for the bot username. So you can put like bottle underscore Justin's underscore bot if you want.
I just do bottle pot
Let's see if it's
Let's see if that works
Gotcha, it has to be unique.
Sorry, already taken. It's unique names, yeah
Okay.
Okay, great. Okay, now pull it up.
And pull this screen off. You're going to enter the Telegram bot token. So hit enter.
Okay, we're going to start the share here for just a moment.
Okay, that's probably success.
Yeah, that's fine.
Well, I mean, it was a fraction.
We're gonna have to edit this before we send it out, guys, so it might be a little bit delayed. We've got some API tokens. We've got API keys exposed again. Guys, if you were doing this, make sure you do it in a secure fashion, not like we just did, exposing our keys. But Ian, worst case scenario, I just had my keys exposed. What's the worst case scenario that could happen
Well, in that case, it's not that bad. It's your Telegram
The bot token, it's
you would… you could rotate it, you know, if you don't know what rotating tokens is, it means you expire the old one, and you go back and get a new one
So if you do expose it or if it's like, oh, that was in the code or it's somewhere I can't go in and get rid of it, just go say expire that one, create a new one and just start over.
safer this time. That's what I did with Syngrid.
So
It's kind of like the keys to your house, right? You'd never give someone the
Yeah.
the key to your home, unless it's a family member, so you want to keep your keys secured. So, I just plugged in the HTTP API token. It's now asking for the environment variable name
Environment variable name
Oh, open call.
That's why we installed them under, I think
So I can share now because the API is hidden
So again, okay, environment variable name. Oh
environment
Just delete that, or did he put that in there?
That was just auto added
Is missing or empty in this session
Environment variable name
Use external secret provider
Oh, oh, oh, sorry. Okay. I know what this is. So you have to go back to Telegram.
Okay.
And you'll keep it off screen again
And you'll go search for your bot by the username
Bottle underscore whatever it was.
Can I ask at that? What is my environment variable name for bottle bot
No, this isn't a chatbot yet. This is just taking you through the setup
Of that. But at the end of this, he will start chatting and it's a lot of fun.
It's like new life, new birth.
That sounds really weird, actually.
So within Telegram.
I'm going to a website, or I'm talking in Telegram still
Within Telegram, you'll go up to the search bar just like you did Botfather.
Okay.
But this time type in bottle
You know, the username, bottle underscore
Whatever the rest was
Okay.
You can just search for that.
And it should, yep, search for it. It should show up
You can hit
Click on it, and it'll say start
Okay.
And
Does it say, does it give you
API token or a bot token
Bottle bot
No, no, no, yours wasn't bottled by, it was bottle underscore AI for NTP
That's right.
There it is right there
Okay, I'm in here.
Yeah, hello. Okay, did it give you a bot token?
Not yet
Oh, actually go back to Botfather. That's where it is. Go to Botfather, find
Your bot
And it should have those things in there. Your Telegram pairing key and the API or the bot token.
Do you see it?
No, it gave me my HTTP API
I'm gonna find mine
If you
type slash mybots
iBots, okay.
Yeah. Do you see bottle in there?
Yep.
Okay, click on that
And it says API token, edit bot, bot settings, payments.
Oh, sorry. You know what it was back at Bottle Bot. Sorry. Go back to the
the new bot you just created
I did backslash start
Yes.
Does it say anything?
Nothing yet.
Okay.
Let's see, environment variable name
I can't see that. There it is.
Okay, so it's not connected yet. So hit
Go back on the terminal here
Okay.
And did you type in Telegram bot token?
I did, yep.
Okay, erase that and let's just hit enter
Use of NVAR like open class secret uppercase. Oh
Okay, then just put open cloud underscore secret
All uppercase. Uppercase.
Yeah.
Uppercase. See guys, Ian's done this 12 and some change times, and there's still some
roadblocks you run into. But always figure it out.
Pretty much every time because it kind of changes in this session.
Hold on, let me
Yeah, they're only giving updates
Let me, let me ask my bot right now. This is where other bots come in really handy. So I always say.
I always say if you're gonna install one on open class because if one goes down and it almost always will for some reason or another, then you can have another one that actually will bring it back to life.
And it's very, very helpful.
And it can get into its business, into its code, and
Oh, now Ian's dead. Let me try another
So you're saying you have your bot help you with
roadblocks, technical roadblocks
Yes.
Oh, now he's talking yet. Okay, that's fine. We'll have a bot race, see which one responds fastest. Yes, I have… I have one of my bots will connect to all of my… my other bots, and so when they go down, I go to him, his name's Atlas, and I say, hey, go check him out. He's not responding, or she's not responding.
And usually says, okay, I see what happened. I restart her, she's fine, you know, and they come right back to life
Before that, I had to troubleshoot all this myself, usually with Claude or OpenAI. But at the time, they didn't even know what OpenClaw was. They were like, oh, you mean open source or open call? I was like, no.
this website, go to this website, and you can actually go to openclaw.com, I believe, or openclaw.ai
And a lot of the stuff is is
Is in there. Okay.
Fastest way is to export… okay, Justin, I'm gonna give you a
I'm going to give you
Put this in here, and you replace it, I'm putting this in chat
Okay.
And just replace it. So, export open class, secret equals
Whatever you know 1, 2, 3, like
Okay.
I'm doing this in DigitalOcean.
Wait.
Oh
Reload
Okay.
We didn't update it fast enough. Go to OpenClaw config. OpenClaw space config.
Type that in
Yeah.
Local this machine
Okay, we got the model, so Workspace is where it lives, like what folder model is what model it's using. Web tools are things like skills, where you can install things that will allow it to create PDFs or
Search the web, have a browser, or even talk to you. There's one called Whisper that I think Alec was using on our last call
that can actually talk, you can do a TTS, text-to-speech or speech to text STT.
So we won't do those now because we can install them later. But go down to channels. That's where we want to get this Telegram thing working.
Add or update channels. Yep.
go down to Telegram
Yep.
It is. Yeah, Darien, it is a lot
Inter Telegram bot token, hit enter, and it's going to ask you for it
Okay.
Now, you can take it off screen into that bot token you have
It's giving me the
HTTP API token, is that correct?
No, you want to go to the bot father
and go to your bot Api token.
Okay
And that's what you'll plug in there.
But you want to do it off screen.
There we go.
Okay, there we go.
So, okay, there we go. The clack
Didn't we ever do this telegram
Telegram bot API.
Hit enter
Wait, actually, wait, no, no. Sorry. Skip, leave as is.
So just go up one arrow goes to finish at the bottom. Hit enter. Oops.
Okay.
Great.
So configure DM access. No, you don't need to do that now. We'll do it later.
Okay, so now you've set up everything. There are skills there. So web tools are one thing. Skills are another. We don't need to do any of these right now.
You can just go up one arrow and say done
And say open claw, this is when it gets fun. Open claw
Gateway, Space Gateway
Start.
I've survived more… I've survived more braking changes than your last three relationships.
Mike
Oh, sorry, look, it says disabled. What does he say? I survived more breaking changes than you are. Yeah, true. Okay, go open gateway install.
One word or two.
It's always one word.
Open claw, you can actually copy that if you want, but just gateway install.
So Gateway is the thing that starts it up and connects it to your Telegram and basically keeps it alive. So it's the funnel out. It's this doorway out of
just being on a server. No gateway token.
What does that say?
Auto-generated one having
And saving the config. Okay, so now I'll say open cloud. If you just hit up arrow twice
Try that.
Open Cloud Gateway is start
Yep.
And you said the same thing
I speak fluent
Bash, mild sarcasm. Okay, we started. Okay, so now go over to your Telegram
Okay.
And to pull up that bot, the new one.
And say something, hi.
Oh, okay.
That was not super crucial, but now we need to
Do a pairing thing. So
I'm asking my bot right now. I forget
It also changes every time there's new open class. So open clause also open source. So everybody, a lot of people are working on it. And they all get changes get pushed to
to GitHub
And when they're… when the whole community says, yeah, these are approved, these are good, then
they'll get a new version when pushed up. So 2026.6.5, that's the newest version
Which means it's 5 days old. Usually, back when I started, there was one or several every day, new versions, because it was just constantly being bombarded with new changes. And every time they'd push a new change, things change with how you set it up like this.
Again, why it's really helpful to have a bot who can go look at the GitHub repo and say
Oh
Okay.
Okay, I'm seeing your stuff, Justin
So
What you want to do is
Here, I'll paste it to you directly so that
Paste the bot token. You see that there?
Yep.
Ian, we're gonna have to send out some robust instructions for anyone in the audience who wants to set this up on their own time
Yeah, this is the most technical part right here.
The other stuff was just, like, updating stuff, but this is the part that
Sometimes it goes super smooth and fast, sometimes it's like, I've been on the call for an hour or two
So yeah, I'm putting this in DigitalOcean, what you just sent me
Yeah, in this thing right here
In DigitalOcean or in Telegram?
And DigitalOcean.
Because it's gonna… this is where it connects your Telegram channel to that bot and says, okay, we're synced. So it's a pairing
Token, actually the parent code
John, Lawrence, yes, there is an agent. Well
My agent could set yours up, but it would have to have access to your server or computer, but that's pretty much how I do it
anymore. I just go and say, hey, start me up in OpenClaw on this server. And it gets it going.
The first one's the hardest, but yeah, hit us up. We can we can figure out how to
How to
Get you one. What is this?
Getting approved. Okay
Okay, go back to your bot, Justin.
Yeah, on Telegram.
Yeah. And just say like slash new.
Is it asking for a pairing token?
I just say hello to it. Let's see if it responds.
Okay.
You're not sharing your screen anymore, but
Oh, there we go.
Oh, there we go
He's alive
Salah he
Looks like I'm fresh here. I love this first line. It's always the best. So I'm still figuring out who I am.
in your workspace from OpenCloud
He did it.
What should I call you, and what should you call me? So this is where you're… this is actually kind of a crucial yes, all the applause. I agree. This is a big moment for Justin and me, because I've been telling about this for months
And he's been too busy, and I'm like, dude, there's… you can't be too busy for Telegram, or for
Open clock. Okay, so this is where you give it its first instructions. You say, your name is whatever, my name is, and here's what you're here for
And
When you give it these instructions, it will actually commit it to memory
And say, okay.
I am this person, and these are my rules, right? Or this person, this bot, and here, these are my rules
Yeah, and whenever it says typing there, you love that, because it means it's thinking, and it's working, and it's about to say something. And sometimes it'll be typing for a while, doing a lot of thinking
But if it doesn't say typing
Or it's printing out a bunch of this. This is a bunch of
code that it's doing, you don't have to worry about it, and you can say, hey, turn this off. I don't want to see that. And he can do it.
But with every update, it tends to
It tends to come back. So
So yeah, I use Claude code on a daily basis to build apps and projects and RevOps, marketing, all the above
in which scenarios am I going to want to use to use bottle instead of
Claude code. Is this for different workflows, or could you help me understand why I'm going to be using an agent in Telegram versus working out of Codex?
Or clock code
Sorry, I was responding to AM.
Why you would use OpenClaw versus Claude code
Yep.
So OpenClaw is very agentic and deterministic. It wants to, if you give it a command.
It wants to figure out any way it can to make that command come true
Whereas Claude will say, oh, in order to do that, you'll need to go to this website and sign up for a thing and get whatever else. But these guys can get into everything. Like someone earlier was asking about Google email and Google Docs and Google, you know, calendar
You can get him access to it. That one you will have to, because I've set him up as a user, but once you have that, he has it in his memory, he'll just go and do that stuff. Whereas Claude Code, or Claude, you're working on your local machine. It's not really
It's not really very easy to push stuff out to the internet
And it's also, if you guys have ever used… what's the mode in Claude Code when it's, like, ridiculously unchained or whatever, you know, where it has, like
Auto mode or yeah
Yeah, where they have like almost no approvals. This one has
almost, almost no, like .01 time percent will ask for approval, you know?
Oops.
That was to me, just only Justin.
You're still talking to me in chat.
Oh, good. I'll send them a follow up.
So
So Yi, now here we are. What's something cool? I could give it a personality or tell them they're a expert in revenue operations, helping companies scale, helping small businesses copyright better. I'm an author of a book. I need you to be a proofreader
Yeah
edit the SEO, my website, like, there's all kind of different instructions and rules you could give at this point, right? But what do you think would be really interesting for us to demo live before we jump into Q&A?
Let's see. Actually, before you do, I say, hey, what's your server look like? What's the space you're in look like?
Visually or just
No, just say that and it'll come back with stuff.
So now it's going and reviewing the box, the server that it's on. And it's going to give you all the specs
And it'll tell you, basically, I will oftentimes say, how much room do you have? And it'll tell me, oh, I have 30 gigabytes left, we're plenty of room to build stuff, you know
It's bubbling
So just to show you a couple tips and tricks like this, it can also
They can download, hey, go search for this on the internet and it'll say, oh, let me download headless Chrome first or some browser
And if it may ask you for an API token for Brave or something like that, and you say, I don't want to get that, I don't have that, then it will just go and say, oh, let me figure out something and it'll figure it out, you know
And it's really awesome
Yeah, that's cool.
So you can you can tell it it's it's very defined
Like
purposes, like, but it's kind of important to know what you want it to do before starting one. It's not crucial, but that will help it a lot. So some of mine are on production servers, and I say, you don't touch anything on production unless I have my approval.
And it marks that in its memory, long-term memory, and so every time now it says, I'm going to make this change. Once I have your approval, here's what I'll do, right?
And it remembers that for months, you know.
Yeah, this is a great question.
If you don't know what
what it's for, you can ask that. Well, it'll probably ask you
It's taking a long time on that server question.
All right, Fernanda.
You know, thank you.
Thanks for being here.
Guys, any questions?
I know we're short on time. We were hoping to have more time for
A live walkthrough of what it can do
Aaron, thank you so much for joining guys, and shout out to everyone who showed up today, 6 PM Eastern
I know
I know we're always a global audience, but like this is really
An incredible time to be alive. I mean, we didn't show much of this tool and how to use it, but really the sky's the limit with AI and what you can do with it.
It's just limited by your imagination. If you see it and believe it, you can really do it with the right tools and resources. Ian Debbie has a question.
Yeah, Elder.
That actually is a really good
Oh, wait, we also had a question arrived late. How do I see? Okay, that was a while ago. So, Debbie Elder, yes, you could actually have it set up another open call right then. In fact.
Looks like
Oh, you know what? Go back to the
This section, I'm glad this happened. Go back to the terminal on DigitalOcean.
And hit open claw, Gateway Restart
Because I forgot, this is something that does happen, and I'm glad this will be on the recording because it will
The gateway will die, or if you get logged out or close the terminal window. And so you can actually go and once he's restarted
He'll start talking again
Let's see here
It's thinking. I think the computers or the server is
Being taxed. But you can say, hey, do whatever you need to do to stay alive so I can close the terminal window or so when I
So you don't die on me, you know? You can talk very human to it as well, and it'll understand. Oops.
So while that's coming back alive, it looks like your server may be, maybe that was the wrong question to ask under first. Like, hey, what kind of room do you have on the server?
Because
It's like taking a while
But yes, setting up another open call on the server, you can actually set one up on the same place and go through the same process
don't go… actually, you wouldn't go through the same process. You would say, set one up for me, named whatever
And, it'll set it up for you, and then you can actually go through the whole Telegram process and say
now connected to this. Here's my peering token, here's my bot token, and it'll set it all up, then you just go find your bot on Telegram, whatever you named it
and start talking to it. So then you have two bouncing off the same server in different folders
So if one of them dies and it invariably will.
Then you messaged me again only, Justin. Not sure why it keeps going back to that.
Yes, Ronnie, we will send
We'll send the video
Okay, there we go. I can help the pretty broad speaking. Okay, here we go.
Yep, I'm here. So
We have the server back up and running
There's another thing, so whenever you type in something to Telegram, if you type in, like, 5 messages, like, hey, are you there? Are you alive? Where'd you go, bottle? Don't leave me! It's gonna read each one in succession and respond to it. So it's gonna read, hi.
Hi, are you there? Yes, I'm here. What's going on? Are you alive? Yes, I'm alive. What's going on? You know, it'll respond so you can actually tell it, hey, if I ever spam you with questions about if you're alive, just read them all and respond one time
But it's also true if you give it a command and then say, oh, wait, no, don't do that. It's going to do it first and then it'll roll it back. Just so you guys know.
These are some of the things you have to some of the nuances that I've had to figure out.
Can I do an SEO audit of
AI for NTP
Let's just see what it's capable of. This is fun
Ian, we're going to have to do another one of these. I'll edit it. Make it very streamlined step by step instructions for anyone who wants to set this up on their own. We can also get you guys in the community
So we can help you troubleshoot and work out these kinks, because it is still very new technology
So everyone here is an early adopter. You can be like Ian, have 12 bots running all your businesses
Let's see, we might have to set up a fire crawl or something, Ian, to get it to
Check it out.
Yeah, it can do all that. It can do some on its own. Fire crawl is a great one for it to go scrape a lot of pages
And
Yeah, there's just so much. Now that we've actually set up an open claw and we've done it live, and there's other parameters things that you, if you want to set up with WhatsApp or if you want to set it up on another server or whatever, local MacBook Pro or something.
Those are also other ways, but those are really just variations on a theme. But now that it's set up, now we can actually do a deep dive on what's possible with this. And it is, in my opinion, it's the most valuable
Software out in the world right now
nothing even comes close.
I guess Claude and them are starting to get closer, but they still have so many guardrails and parameters on them
That this one for a guy like me who is an entrepreneur, inventor, you know, everything, builder
And I know UX, so I can actually guide it in that stuff, it's just, like, it's being, like, being in heaven
So this is called doing a full SEO audit. Guys, while it's doing this audit, if you guys want to come on stage, ask a question, you can raise your hand if you'd like to talk on stage. You can drop it in the chat here
Any questions, comments? Typically, these sessions we've been doing one every week. Last week was a hackathon. That was super fun and interactive
David, I appreciate you, man, good to see you again. We're doing a new one
You don't need 12 darium. One will do. Two is better because then they can help each other
But I'm going crazy. That's what I do. So you don't need 12.
Jamie says, as an entrepreneur, what are your favorite use cases with OpenClaw E?
That is a great question. And
I can spend the next hour talking about that, but
Honestly, some of it was
Just finding some small niches that needed value, that needed help. You know, I found one, the very first one I had built, my first
bot build is named Enoch. It was called Mini Match, mini match.app, but I'll put it in the thing so you guys can see it.
It probably won't
Let me type match.app. It probably won't mean anything to you guys because it's for a very small niche audience who plays Warhammer 40, 40,000 or other similar games.
Thanks, Ronnie. Ronnie, Roni.
And it's basically a way for them to track their paints when they get these little characters on their games, they paint them and they apparently it's like 3 to 5 million worldwide that do this. And they lose track of their paints. So I built an app and launched it to the App Store
For them to track their paints, you know, and I talked with my bot and said, how should I price this? And it said, for this audience, you don't want to do it monthly because they're going to look at it as like a big business coming in and trying to make money off this little their craft
And so I did an upgrade to Pro one-time payment, but it's also very useful without that. And so I thought, well, that was more of a use case. That was fun
But then I started building things like Echo check, Classicov, which is
LMS system for white label system for classical schools. Pretty much all the business ideas I had, or any that looked interesting to me, I built 10 businesses in 10 weeks, January 24th to April 4th
And I'm still going strong on those.
And
So, I don't know if that helps
Well, I mean
Are these small businesses? Do you have big global businesses? Give us an idea of the businesses you're running with these agents. Not to put you on the spot, but putting you on the spot here. I think we'd love to know.
Some are small. I mean, Mini Match is a little app. You know, I made one called Pedal Map. I didn't launch that yet because I hit some snags and wanted to think through it for guitarists for pedals, making pedal boards. Solo Mio is another one I'm working on that's going to
Kind of replace QuickBooks. As an entrepreneur, I always wished I had a certain financial program that worked for me, and so I built it, and I'm building it, and I intend to launch that as well.
brand sauce, I didn't build brand sauce with AI, but it's definitely built… been built a lot by AI. And that's my main company that is global.
Echo check, which is like SEO for AI, to how to be found by AI. So it's more of a intellectual technical guide through how to make your website findable by LLMs, by ChatGPT and Claude, and it's working
And then
Yeah, there's I built actually I had a workout app
that I was paying five bucks a month for that, I didn't… didn't want to pay $5 a month for anymore. So I took screenshots and exported all my stuff and gave it to my bot, and it built a better workout app. So that's what I use now
And I'll probably put that on the App Store as well. It's called another one
Another1.app. So
It's pretty much
You guys, Ian's one of his superpowers is being very humble. He also has some
global businesses he supports with these agents, and so it's not just for side projects, it's not just for home projects or personal projects. You can really use it to make real impact on
very sizable businesses
As well, so the sky's the limit.
Absolutely. Yeah. I mean, yeah, their arguments are a lot that I've worked with. I have some clients that it builds excellent stuff for them in a fraction of the time
Thank you.
And it's just a lot of fun. I mean, I use it as often as I can
Because it's so valuable. In fact, when there are days when I only use it for like an hour, I'm kind of feel like
It was a wasted day. Wait, I had someone asked up here, someone who's new, how long
Someone who's new, how long would this take me to learn and how could I put small
Small terms so I could understand and make my own apps and bots. Honestly, talking to your bot about whatever it is you want to build is the best way. Follow that curiosity. Say, oh, I like that, tell me more about that.
And follow that thread, it can teach you everything. I've never coded apps on my own. I've tried, but now I've produced a lot of apps with the help of OpenClaws. So talk to your bot, follow the curiosity
It'll teach you. It's like a guide
Ian, please, how do you set up
Yeah, check out this SEO report's fairly robust for a first pass.
Fixing 404s, tightening meta descriptions, updating copy, keyword landing pages
That's great.
Guides, robot text, site map exists
Yeah, so this
Technical nerves
Another thing with it is first pass like this, great. Then you can say, hey, specifically, how do I, whatever that thing is, right? How do I be found by LLMs? How do I
How do I rank first on Google for this search term or whatever? And it'll drill down into things. Right now, it's a general response, but it can drill down, because that's essentially like a 500 IQ best friend that has all the time on the roof for you and never gets tired of your questions
So it's remarkable like that. Let me see Jean-Jacques. Ian, please. How do you set up an AI strategy, UI, UX bot that you presented during a previous section? That is essentially, Jean-Jacques, that's essentially what we just set up here
Mine, I just prompted it to make a brand kit. You have to just say, hey, I'm making a brand kit, put it here. Yeah, DJ, there we go, another one. They got it. I was wondering if people would get that. The websites and anotherone.app
I love it. And actually, my bot posts the blog post there. His name's Ian Khaled. So
Anyways, jokes. But Jean-Jacques, you would basically
Tell it to make a brand kit and then pick the stuff and give it everything you can and then just if the output is not what you want, then just refine it. Keep talking to it and it'll refine that page live wherever you have it posted. So it's not a unique UI UX
But it's for
It's for anything you want. So, okay, let me see what else is there. Recording, do you guys deliverable, I believe this. We did lovable at our last call. Alec did. He uses a lot, gets a lot of great stuff out of it, but
I used it for a little while, and I just… I'm a designer, and so I actually prefer to have my hands on that stuff
So I don't, but Alec does.
Ian, I really like broad design right now. Cloud design is very good right now. Lovable is really nice for one shotting a landing page. If you need something quick and you don't care about having, like Ian was saying, too much control over it, but Ian being a classical designer
It's nice to be able to work and
with, like, Figma MCP with Claude, or something where you can have more control over the dials to tweak things just to your liking, but if you just want something clean and quick, lovable is great
I don't know if they have a free option right now, but I do think they have a fairly cheap entry-level option that
It's really good. We, like Ian said, Alec, who was on the last session, he built a website with it
In what, 10 min and it looks great
Yeah
So Darian said open Claude is the first step to make a bot, right? Well, yeah, OpenClaw with some kind of a brain, like we did on here. In this case, it's ChatGPT 5.5. That's the first step.
Actually, this is an interesting question because what we did here is a VPS. So it's a server somewhere on the internet. It's not on Justin's computer. So it wouldn't actually create the code you would use for an app. It could. You would have to have it push it to GitHub or someplace where you can get
But if you install OpenClaw on your computer, which maybe we can do that next time or record a video for that, then it can actually open up Xcode or Android Studio on your computer or just create the code for you and then you can actually push it if you're on the same network, which
You would be. It can push it straight to your phone from the computer. So you can say, make an app, make it do this, push it to my phone, and it will do that. You have to have test flight from Apple
Or I don't know if Android has something like that, but
Yeah, get the bot, and then just start asking it how to how to build an app.
Darien.
Okay. If I have an app idea with detail, would I just feed that into the bot and ask it to create an app for it? Yeah, I would start by brainstorming
That was Jean Rebel Rebel.
I was taught by brainstorming. Put everything into the bot and then just say, brainstorm this with me. Help me create a build spec.
specifications on the build. So don't let it start building yet. Wait until you think through the whole thing, but it'll help kind of guide you through it. And you can even say, hey, what's something else that we can include into this
into this app, that would be cool. If we're trying to hit this audience, or we want to make money, or what, you know, tell all the things, the goals, and you can be really blunt with it, like, I want to make this much money with it, what do I need to put into it? What do I need to do?
And it will set all that up for you, and then once you're happy with the plan.
you can either have it build it or give it to Claude, or however you want to do it from there
I like to use OpenClaw, so I just say, okay, build it. And he starts building it.
This is really cool, Ed. I just asked it if it has all the context it needs to be an LLM SEO expert or would it be helpful for me to upload help docs for your MD file?
And so it does have enough context. And so E, where is it getting all this context from this bot I'm just talking to in my chat? How does it have all that information already?
Is this a question specific for AI for NTP or just in general, LLM expert?
Yeah, I told Bardo I wanted to be an LLM SEO strategist. It says uploading docs would make me sharper.
But I already have enough context
So where is it
Yeah, so it's
It's using the ChatGPT brain, which I don't even know how many parameters it's been trained on. It's well over a trillion, maybe several trillion. So the parameters and training, so parameters are bits of information. Like, it'll take
Words or documents or files and give it to it and it'll take it all in and store it.
And then that's training it. When it takes it in, it stores it, and so it's been trained on so much, so much. That's why you can ask any question it knows, right? So it has been trained well on LLM SEO strategy, and if it doesn't have training on it, if you ask something specific, like when I asked Claude about OpenClaw.
It says, I don't
All right, thanks, Dean Clark
It said, I don't know about
What that is, I just sent it the website, and then it could go and learn. It basically trained itself. It's not training the big brain, but it's training not… this open claw
So that's how it knows that stuff, and it's true documents or specific things, you can give it to it and it'll say, okay, this is important to Justin or this, this, you know, he gave this to me, so I'm going to read this and pay more attention to this. You know, does that make sense?
Yeah, Ian, we've got to hop in three minutes. I don't know if we'll get to all these questions, but Ian, will you drop your email in the chat if anyone wants to follow up with you? They have a way to reach out. Guys, I want to give you all a shout out for joining. This has been great. I see a lot
Repeat community members here, Peggy from Pittsburgh, we've got Kristen, good to see you again, John, Jude. John Jaquez
Going back.
Debbie, Darian Ashwin, Harlan, Jamie, Jennifer again, Kevin
Wait, wait.
Olga Patricia again, Swaty, Toby, Yazin. Guys, thank you
We have a couple of questions. Do we have time for that or no? We have to jump?
We've got… we've got 2 minutes here. Thank you, Peggy. We'll chat soon.
Okay.
Jamie asked an interesting one, how is this different from using an LLM app? And responses seem slower. They do seem slower right now. I'm not sure why that is. It's not always like that. But these are unhinged. So there's no guardrails, there's no handcuffs on them. It can actually create
web sites, charts, graphs, everything like that for you. So you can actually talk to it in the car, or on the bus, or on the train, and come home, and there's a whole web
platform for you, whereas your LLM app, you have to sit there and either copy the code, or it can mess with it on your computer. You have to upload it. There's just a little bit more clunky, and this one's live
So it can sit on the thing. I use it for a lot of things where I could say, hey, look up this person, did they sign up? Are they having any problems? So it's in the code
So, but it's also scary, you gotta be careful
All right, I think that's it. Some more autonomous. Yes, exactly. More autonomous. Way more autonomous
All right. Thank you, guys. This is a lot of fun.
Eve, what do you think? This was a technical session.
Yeah
Well, the next one, what do you think we should do? Maybe another hackathon or
I like the AI improv we did. That was fun.
Yeah, improv was fun
Yeah, I wouldn't mind one of those
For those of you who didn't join, we did
Within an hour, we built an entire company from scratch using AI. Ian did the branding and design. Alec did the website, and then I did the go to market marketing strategy. It was fun, super, super educational on how to use the AI tools
Shows what's
Yeah.
capable in under an hour or so we'll send you guys all a note. John Rebel the website I'll drop in the chat. You can register there, get all our information.
For future sessions. Again, we're trying to do these once a week. And Ian, the big idea we've been talking about is there's a lot of gatekeepers of AI. They use it for themselves. They keep all the secrets kind of to their so they can profit from it. But our ethos here is to share everything we know
Yeah.
And be transparent in our, you know, in our community. So any questions you guys ever have, Ian and myself are available to steer you in the right direction, send resources. We're building a big resource and tool hub on the website. We have all the recordings on our YouTube and website
Show notes, FAQs, so
Just let us know how we can help, and that's what AI for non-technical people is all about
Yep.
Love it. Hope this was valuable to you guys. Thank you for joining.
See you chat soon. Thank you, Debbie.
It doesn't.
Thank you, Darian.